we'll have somebody transfer those
that Len and I can see them
this first
two-part question is basically how much
experience she has to give a letter an
idea of who's in the audience today
and also we've been checking in with
people during the pandemic about how
they're holding up to
lockdowns coming and going surges coming
and going
we hope that we're on the other side of
all of that there's no no new variants
coming to get us but
I just want to see how everyone's doing
close the poll in about three seconds
here we go
the link you can see that we have an
audience that's uh pretty seasoned we
have about uh almost 50 percent of the
people have more than 10 years of
experience
um and it's good to see that
98 of our audience which is the highest
number
we've seen in a while uh are doing uh
okay or better so that's that's very
heartening
um
I shouldn't introduce myself my name is
Stuart Creek I'm a marketing manager
here at simply learn
um lenbertain and I go back quite a long
time from one of my very first jobs
and I met him there and
um we've been friends for uh
the decades since so
um I'm gonna let Lynn talk about himself
a little bit more and explain what it is
that the CEO uh I'm sorry the
construction of problem solvers does but
um
then we will get into the presentation
so land over to you
oh you're unmute I'm sorry
I forgot to warn you that the
system YouTube as soon as we go live
hold on a second I'll fix that
participants
I gotcha
all right yeah we can hear you now okay
very quickly what we do is
uh I have a number of facilitators who
work with me to
help companies solve problems we get
people online
uh could be anywhere in the world and
they can work together four or five six
people per team working through the
problem process that we've developed
um
literally over those 35 years actually
it's 39 now
um and we've been very successful
um like Stuart said we've done a lot of
transformation business transformation
over those years and
it's actually been an exciting
experience and what we're going to be
talking about today is
one of the ways I look at transformation
business transformation
with the design thinking that you are
learning as well as my experience as a
physicist
so the goal today is to use scientific
thinking to look at how you do design
transformation
and using design thinking to come
combine them both when you're looking at
doing that
um
so I'd like to just sort of read this
because you know this is something that
is the key to this whole presentation is
that why do you even want to discuss an
analogies from science and it would
it should go without saying that one
cannot expect to be successfully steer a
dynamically complex business system
moving as
Bill Gates says moving business at the
speed of light
through a thirstly competitive and
ever-changing Global Marketplace without
an adequate grasp of how and why
organizations are the way they are and
behave the way they do so our primary
purpose in doing this analysis is to
transfer an understanding of science to
a business
using the power of the scientific
Paradigm to improve managers
understanding decision-making
Communications and performance so that's
the foundation of what we're going to be
talking about today
so what is the scientific thinking that
we're talking about it's basically
looking at organizations resemble things
that are uh are
the systems of science basically and the
systems of nature
there's a and we see a strong
correlation between
analogies that link a business
in a science and if you could describe
nature with some Precision then you can
draw the analogy over into the
management systems which describe the
business
and it's also an approach to business
which recognizes organizations or
structures that mimic systems in nature
and finally the scientific Paradigm
provides a set of lenses about how we
look at the world
and
I'll try to go through some of that
today so
um
Stuart
this all starts with something I I
observed a long time ago no blame
and many of you sort of shake your heads
I'm probably saying I'm not in my
company well but you can't do business
change
transformation
design transformation without the no
blame philosophy in place
it's just not going to happen
and it just quickly when I when I
started this years ago one of the
employees when I said he put an idea
into play immediately turned around
looked the back of the room see if any
of the jerk managers were there and then
he put his idea into play and then
I realized that no blame
is the foundation of both the scientific
Paradigm scientific thinking and design
thinking is that you have to have that
as the foundation of your process Stuart
a years ago I put this together about
how science relates to business I'm not
going to be able to go into the details
of this over the course of the day but
I'm going to cover bits and pieces of it
but this is a a rather lengthy chart to
really understand in detail but it
starts with science on the left and what
are the elements of science that we want
to bring into the business world and so
for at the top you have a mindset
and curiosity and questioning are the
sort of the key foundations of Science
and so you bring those over into
business and
you are looking at attitudes in business
and we're going to go into this in a
little bit more detail and the
leadership styles the kinds of things
that you want in a business
then you go down on the left side you go
down into
the investigation analysis and
explanation and then that becomes uh the
elements that you use from science or
observing experimenting measuring
and I put in something there that's what
we call charting chalking the field and
we'll explain that uh during the course
of this presentation on the right hand
side you've got
all of the things that you need to do
effectively investigate and do the
analysis in a business
then you move down on the left to this
basic truth and those are sort of the
the laws of physics biology chemistry
geology all of the sciences that we know
and we get into the right hand side the
things that relate to business or
Mission core values how it's structured
strategy Etc these are all things that
comprise the basic truth so to speak of
business
and when you when you look for instance
at Mission and your your company I
always laugh at this uh in about
night it was
2005. I couldn't still remember the day
I went into a CEO's office and I said uh
we were talking for a couple of minutes
I said can I see your business plan
and he looks around and he he goes a
good stands up goes over to a file door
can't find it and he goes
Madge or whoever secretary was and says
can you find my business plan and he's
so finally he brings it out and he has
all of the things that you see there the
mission the core values
structure strategy and so I asked him
about what is can you repeat this you
know your nine strategic objectives and
you know he struggled so the message is
those things have to be active right in
front of you all the time in order to
make them work just as you do in the
basic truest of science
and Technology and Engineering and the
in the fourth level down you get down to
down the tactics of how you're going to
evolve the actions that are going to
make things happen in the organizations
so I'd like to just spend a minute a few
minutes on each of these the attitudes
um
the determination
sort of what you're looking at here is
how is this organization going to learn
and apply the what we've learned to put
it in a protect context of business so
that we can compete effectively
so you look around in the industry to
see what the best thinking is you read
the Harvard Business Review to get
attitudes defined there from
key thinkers in the industry you want to
be in a continuously
learning Norm you're you're just seeking
more information
Stuart
the determination of
of how you learn
you basically want to make sure that
when people work go to work at your
company or in your business that they
want to learn and if you don't have
somebody that wants to learn or improve
themselves
uh it's really there's really shouldn't
be a new place for them
um
you want to study the best thinking and
making sure that creativity is part of
each person's job you know that you want
people to put ideas into play but then
part of that is if they're going to put
an idea into play you have to have
systems that allow them to put those
ideas into play without
blame it without interference from
managers that think it's their job to
interfere
so the job of leadership in this kind of
an organization is
critical
next story
the work style is sort of like
it's what I was referring to a second
ago if managers can
have to be leaders and influencers
instead of uh detail Micro Managers
um it's been it's not been my experience
by from either as in a an employee or as
a consultant
to walk into a company where there's a
micro manager that's been very
successful
they may be for a short time but it's
not a long-term approach to uh
to effectively running an organization
but the key to this getting back to the
scientific uh thinking is that you have
to be able to challenge things with the
ability to question and doubt somebody's
position and without uh consequences
uh without reprisal so anyway this is
effectively changed without reprisal
Stewart
a lot of times people when we're working
with companies you know you ask somebody
what what are the items that they're
being measured on and they sort of know
I really don't know what
and a lot of times when I go into
companies it's surprising going back a
step from Beyond this is asking somebody
what is it you do that adds the value
in the company or
if you're if you're not a value-added
person what are you doing to support the
adding a value so when we chalk the
field we Define what a person's job is
and we of course then set the boundaries
of what we expect them to be doing so we
use the Expression chalking the field
uh I found this picture somewhere on the
internet and it's just it really makes
the point that you know you've got a
line that's guiding the setting of the
boundaries and the guys the boundaries
of individuals working are set by the
strategy and tactics of the organization
Stuart
innovating is really an integral part of
the whole process we're talking about of
scientific thinking
um
you you really want
to make sure continuous learning is is
an integral part of the process
um
you you know
um
when you're trying to
establish
you know hire somebody for instance and
you're trying to interview them and find
out
whether they're an innovating kind of a
person or whatever or they're just you
know sometimes you need worker base
that'll just go in do their job and you
know work eight to five and never really
do any thinking but you really don't
want want that and over the years when
I've done
my uh
problem solving work with companies
down at the lowest level people
understand they understand what they're
trying to do when they're trying to help
the company and if you give them an
opportunity to say I you know I see a
problem here and I'd like to fix it and
they go well your job is to just to do
and not think and unfortunately that's
not the way people are people are
creative people are thinking all the
time in their job and so the idea of
scientific thinking applied to the
lowest level person in the company is
sometimes
uh difficult for some companies to
absorb but when I was able to get people
you know CEOs to see groups of people
working together to solve a problem they
they really got it they they started to
say well [ __ ] I make a lot of money with
these guys
solving these problems I'm going to do a
lot of that and so what I found in
recent years because I'm doing things
online is that people really
can get into this and there and there's
a backlog of ideas that I try to manage
effectively to to keep it within four
weeks so that somebody has an idea that
within four weeks that idea will start
to be acted on by a team that's assigned
to work on it and
um you know but when you start to see
the creativity that comes out of these
teams that I've worked with it's to me
it's always been the most exciting part
of my job is to see some low-level
worker sitting in a class with a PhD in
chemistry or something and saying well
geez why don't you do this
probably my funnest one there was when
I was this literally I think was the
second company I worked with there was a
lady that was the secretary
and
she was working with a group of four
Machinists
and um
these guys were used to cutting
stainless steel and they were talking
about moving to making a product out of
aluminum and they couldn't get the time
to produce the part down low enough to
make it a profitable change of of their
product
and she goes well why don't you just
turn up the feeds and speeds
now to have that if a guy on the shop
floor said that you wouldn't think twice
about it but this is a secretary and she
was listening to this and I said well
you're cutting aluminum you can go
faster you go by three times faster and
they go every single guy on that team
you know hits his forehead and goes like
what do they think of that well the
reason you want all those ideas to play
into the Innovation is that everybody
has ideas and that's that's the message
Stewart
would you interpret information
there are
a ton of tools available Financial
statistical analysis all the kinds of
tools that you can do mathematical
uh things and I'm not going to spend any
time here but it's it's just that you
need tools to be able to do the amazing
amount of information
analysis that's required in the in
today's world and you know each each
company has Specialists doing this work
and
uh you know I'm I'm actually amazed at
what some of these people were able to
do you know like take patterns of
information and and extract those from
the massive amounts of data that that
are available and so what we do when
we're in with a company and they
identify a problem we won't know
necessarily how to solve it but we'll
say oh there's somebody under a company
that knows how to do it or we can find
somebody so
steward
the interesting last sort of last part
of this is trying to get an
understanding of how a business works
you know everybody says well yeah just
come in you come up with a strategy you
have a few tactics to make sure that
you're staying on board to implement the
strategy and
whoop whoop and everything happens but
there's more to it than that each
company is unique in how they actually
function and how they uh
get things done
but probably one of the most difficult
things to work with is when you ask
somebody why are you doing that
particular job the way you're doing it
is
oh that's the way we've always done it
and I go
who told you to do that and I said I
don't know when I got here this is the
way we did it
so people
have to under question why they're doing
things there's a my bullet there
business myths
is probably
wastes more time in companies than any
other uh thing I've had to deal with
because people believe things have to be
a certain way because that's the way
they were trained and a lot of times the
manager
or owners of businesses that we dealt
with
hadn't paid attention to the detail of
what was going on how people were making
the part and assembling it and uh
you know the point I have on there
called they say
you know that is probably one of the you
know when somebody says that another
another company I think I'm at a
shooting because
the the history of
misinformation within companies is
really one of the biggest waste
and
and that's you know I've always had to
fight that from day one in a company
well we've always done it this way
how a business really works
that I want to jump in with an
observation um
the Walt Disney Company
um kind of lost its way after
Walt Disney died
because for many years
everyone in management there said well
what would Walt do they needed to make a
decision they tried to put themselves in
the mindset of Walt Disney and figure
out how he would do it except they were
thinking of Walt Disney at one point in
time when he was
at the end of his career and they didn't
realize that what what Walt did
throughout his career was
you know adapt innovate adopt new ways
of doing things new styles of Animation
you forms of popular music and he never
um Stood Still or had one set way of
looking at the world so it wasn't until
they started dropping that mindset of
it's always been done this way and and
Walt said uh they were able to move
forward and
create some of the things that we know
as uh
iconic Disney films and experiences from
the last 30 years
you know just as a another icon of the
industry Ray Dolby was one of my clients
and
he had a management philosophy as
management by leaving it alone it was
um
everybody within Dolby Studios is nosy
and so somebody would put an order in
and um
they put it in a single spot within the
thing and then there were people that
been in the company a long time and they
came by and they looked at the orders
that were coming in from all of the
different Dolby
clients that they would look at it and
they'd go oh if we do this if we take
this order this way we're going to have
this problem so you get feedback by uh
people being uh caution uh Curious and
interested in not letting the company
screw up and so he he managed what he
called management by leaving it alone
uh and but he he also was a very smart
guy and he uh
when he came up with his original
patents on uh
sound
um
control
um
he
he made it wrote apart and that allowed
him to continually keep that patent into
play for 50 years
anyway the next one's the Stewart
so
when we get into the details of this
testing facts and ideas going back to
that slide
you really want to demand evidence you
do do not want to accept I mean when you
do this as a a worker bee demanding
evidence from your boss you're going to
get fired but if the company adopts uh a
no-blame philosophy that everybody
should be able to ask uh
to get the basis of what it when when
some decision is made
uh
allow for some critical uh in input
there
and the ability to speculate is part of
what makes Silicon Valley and Bay Area
in California very productive because
there's so many young people working
there and they're
uh bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and
they're willing to put ideas into play
and speculate uh about what can be done
is really an important part of this
whole process especially particularly
the uh when you look at uh
things that don't make sense
incongruities in a business
um you should be allowed to question
those and making sure that they're part
of your everyday
challenge when you're going to work
um
just as an aside there when I
was working at a Silicon Valley company
years ago I was told
that we wanted you to be challenging me
as a man who got my manager said I want
you to challenge me and everything else
and so
I said well okay yeah that makes sense
you know and then I went ahead and I you
know he'd come up with an idea at a
meeting and I'd say why were you doing
that it doesn't make sense you know
and then I give you my 10 cents and of
course everybody would jump in after I
had put my foot out but I
years later when I met him he said you
know he said I always used to hate you
when you came into a meeting and I said
well
the feeling's mutual you know but anyway
my this is to me what what working in a
business is all about looking testing
facts and ideas getting the base to the
root of the problems that are staring
you in the face and not being afraid to
to face them
Stuart yeah this is uh by the way the
the analogy is the the Fable of The
Emperor's New Clothes because
businesses get these
fixed ideas about how things work and
why they're successful and it takes uh
someone with a childlike it'll like uh
like land to say well wait a minute I
don't think that that works I think that
the emperor is naked and once that one
person does it you can start uh
everybody else can jump in with I know
motivations about reality so I know the
first day I started at this company I
they handed me the manual
and to look manual for a new product
they were coming out with and I opened
it up and the first page was how to open
the box that the product came in and I
so immediately when I went to my boss
and I said it
is this a joke and he looks at it and he
goes ah [ __ ] explode I'm sorry he said
oh darn and
um
they immediately fix that because you
want to put that instructions on top of
the box not inside it in the manual
so yeah if you've opened the box to get
the manual you probably figured it out
there you go
yeah I'd like to talk a little bit about
some analogies that I use from physics
particularly the one I
on an ongoing basis over and over
um use is the conservation of energy
from thermodynamics
and that relates to
the balance between energy
and entropy entropy is a measure of the
chaos of a company so if you have more
chaos you're going to end up with less
energy so the corollary to that is if
you want to get rid of the chaos you add
energy
but what do you mean by energy
um
I made an observation a number of years
ago that when you look at companies like
GE and Southwest Airlines years ago
GE had a thing called a workout program
and it was sort of like my problem
solving tool and when Jack Welch put
that into play that added a lot of
energy to the company
and the the idea
that energy
that people got excited about working on
trying to fix the problems that GE had
uh
put a lot of energy into the company and
the consequences of that were profits
and uh yeah
improved Revenue just went through the
roof that you eat when those were going
on but after a couple of years
people lost you know the company started
to lose a little bit of the energy that
it had when they were working initially
on some of these problems so we had to
come up with another
call it uh touchy feely thing which
people used to tell me ah you're another
one of those touchy-feely things and I
say no I'm a problem Salt Lake
okay and problem solving is that sort of
the basis of all energy input systems is
that you're trying to use the the
act of solving a problem to keep the
energy active in the company
and when that falls off
that that's the that's the issue that
we're dealing with
and you could think of it another way I
always use the analogy of my wife and I
would go out on a uh for a way for a
weekend and my oldest son and the we try
to manage his two younger brothers and
the place would be chaos when we came
back we came back in put a little bit of
energy into our house and
got the house cleaned up and we were
back to normal again but
the the lack of the input of energy was
called my wife's continually
badgering the boys to keep their rooms
clean and whatever that's the energy I'm
talking about and it may be on an
ongoing basis or maybe one big source of
energy input whatever but there has to
be energy input to avoid the chaos
and then
the uncertainty principle of quantum
mechanics is another good example is the
idea there that when you are trying to
measure something the measure can
interfere with the another
uh
piece of information you're trying to
get like momentum and uh velocity and
position are
counterbalanced if you know one you
don't know the other and so you have a
problem of measurement there and years
ago there was an uh a study done it was
called the Hawthorne study at the
Hawthorne plant in California by
Sylvania which was a light company and
they turned the lights on
and that we're trying to measure the
effect of light on productivity and they
turn the lights up people productivity
went up they turn them up a little more
they went up a little more but then when
they turned them down
productivity kept going up turned it
down again they kept moving the lights
up and down and productivity kept going
up every time they made the change
so the conclusion was that white
intensity had nothing to do with it but
the people that the company was paying
attention to the light intensity at
their workbench
and the people reflected that and
increased productivity so
there there's a some correlation there
between
the science
the uncertainty principle
in the Hawthorne effect
Stuart
there are plenty of analogies from
biology
uh one of my sons was a is a biologist
and
plant genetics biologists
and he was taking a class on plant
morphology
I had no idea what he was talking about
but it turns out plants are pretty
rigorous in their response to Danger
and they create strong barriers of
countering
um
chemicals to fight predators
and you know the question is is what's
the difference between what a business
does when challenged by competitors
and that that to me people have come up
to me years later and said that analogy
was very it sticks with them because
you know animals are continually dealing
with this uh and a vegetable like a
plant can has the same issue
so how we deal with these challenges
from competitors is what uh is that you
know we're not alone in the world when
we have competitors so or Predators if
in the case of plants
stewards
all right are there any questions and
answers
yeah we've got a couple of questions
that have come in and I expect we'll be
getting some more here
um and if you do have questions for um
for Len please put them in the Q a box
but we have a couple that came in
already
um
so sangram was looking at the slides he
saw that there's similar definitions
the attitude aspect and The Innovation
aspect
and um he was curious to know how well
correlated those two aspects are and I'm
going to go back to your main diagram to
let you illustrate the answer
the question was I I didn't quite catch
when you look at attitudes and
Innovation how how
how closely correlated are those two
factors in business
oh
absolutely uh
for instance as an ex one extreme you
can have a a person with uh
I'm the most I'm the brightest guy on
this planet
and
having him as the
lead guy
uh
people working for him are gonna you
know are going to be less than excited
to to do so but when I was at Intel
there was a guy by the name of Ted Huff
and
he came up with all the main ideas the
1001-bit chip the 4004 chip
um
the first microprocessor
uh the 80 80
he was sort of and also the single board
computers he was a big
innovator but he was also a team player
so I I don't know if I'm answering your
question but
you know egocentric
Innovation is not
to me the best way to you know if you're
managing a business
um
it's not always the best way to go
however there may be go-to people for
instance a a plant that I a rubber
two retired rubber manufacturing
operation once the general manager there
if I asked him if he had one guy that he
could go to to
start a business and he would say
absolutely this one one guy because he
could fix anything
so there are
aspects of attitude and abilities and
innovation
where you may need an individual but for
the most part I I am
totally into the you know a team effort
to get the quickest results because
people
if if you have an open
system where people can criticize and
improve the ideas they move very quickly
but if you have somebody that's a
control freak
uh I
I am less than excited to work with that
kind of an individual but the question
is whether there's a I've done any
correlations there the absolute answer
is no I have no idea other than what I
just said I've made observations but no
formal correlations
yeah I mean they're correlated but what
Melinda's saying is he hasn't done a
study on the on the formal relationship
but um I I'd like to share an anecdote
then if I may from
the early days of personal computing
and this illustrates exactly what you
were talking about
um 1984 Apple computer introduced the
Macintosh everybody was
very excited because
it was one of the first personal
computers with the graphical user
interface
and it was an all-in-one box
um self-contained it had a single floppy
disk drive
so it had no internal hard drive storage
and
it was very popular so popular that
within a year there was a
Macintosh conference
worldwide developers conference for
Macintosh and there were exhibitors out
there so Steve Jobs was giving a talk
about
developing the Macintosh
19 November 1984 and a question came up
from the audience said when will you add
an internal hard drive to Macintosh
job said we can't add an internal hard
drive
through the Macintosh
um there's several reasons for that
number one the power supply
won't handle it
and this com this guy said well we're
demonstrating a internal drive
retrofitted into a Macintosh out on the
exhibit floor
we solved the problem by putting in a
new power supply as part of our kit but
guess what the thing is going to
overheat because it has convective
Cooling and you can't possibly
run the hard drive in there without
overheating the unit and they said well
we've included a fan in our kitties well
but then how did you actually even get
it to work with the the processor
there's no
interface bus for a
disk drive and they said yeah we created
a piggyback socket so that we can go
straight into the central microprocessor
chip and use that as our bus and finally
Steve Jobs stood in front of this
audience and said
well it just won't work and of course
they said well if your jobs come out to
our booth and we'll show you but the the
interesting thing about that because of
what we think of Steve Jobs in popular
culture is that in 1984 that was his
attitude
it wasn't until he was fired from Apple
computer and went off and created other
businesses including
taking over Pixar and turning it into
what we know today that
his attitude changed and he began to
trust the people around him to create
amazing things
and not dictate to them
what their creativity ought to be so
that's that by the way Stuart is a
phenomenal example because he was you
know I I knew Steve way back when he
first started apple and
you know I could have joined him and he
was the last person in the world I ever
wanted to work for uh but he is a you
know was very egotistical in his his uh
growth in uh understanding the role of
shared design
was uh was a dramatic change in fact I
think then Bill Gates tell him the iPad
was the single greatest creation that he
ever did was done exactly that way
it has no manual yeah it was a
phenomenal success and
it was a team effort yep yeah and then I
think one of the transition points for
him was when he came back to the company
and and people proposed
they generated the iPod which was a
personal device for listening to music
um some people said the company you know
this personal device we could
add in the features to turn it into a
telephone and
by the way we can make it run apps
so
Steve Jobs initially said you know
nobody wants a all-in-one device that
does all these different things
but he was at that point able to be
persuaded that yeah as a matter of fact
if you take an I thought
add the ability to run apps and add the
ability to make phone calls and add a
camera you now have
um you know a new device that's
unique and lets people do everything
they need to do with
with one thing in their pocket rather
than having to Fumble for three or four
different things carry with them so that
change in Attitude transition point
where he was able to see yeah
letting my team
innovate for me is is giving them the
freedom to do that
is a big big
Force multiplier for our company
um we have
several different questions coming in
one
or a link from the LinkedIn from Dr
Jones asks
how would you apply design thinking in
fashion like design materials or
patterns that type of thing I would
that work
s in that area
actually I have in a
in a sort of a
Jessica McClintock in San Francisco was
a
a dress designer and
uh
but she was a control freak
and
so when I went in and worked with them
she was required by the process that I
used to get input from other people and
so
the people came up with ideas that had
been squelched by her and a lot of them
were just sort of sticking her nose in
these ideas because she was not a
one-to-one accept ideas but I told her
it's either no either you accept no
blame
or I'm out of here and so the the people
that start design companies and
um in the fashion industry
uh are pretty you know pretty
strong-willed individuals and you know
they only get there because they have to
fight like hell to in the industry to
make a success of themselves
and the design
uh if you watch any of the design shows
uh you get a feel for the kinds of
person that you need to be in order to
be successful in that industry
so the answer to your question is I
I work with her just exactly the way I
work with anyone it's no blame
we put an idea together with following
my process we present it to her
uh looking for approval and we get it
done in three weeks we implement the
idea in three to five weeks and
but we instead of trying to solve all of
the problem you take a bite out of the
elephant and do that one and uh
there's locally in the Bay Area there
was a
futon shop
that was a
uh they may
photons and
it was a a collective you know they had
to choose materials to go over the
futons they had canvas coverings of the
base mattress
they had
padding inside the the
futon different blends of wool cotton
uh
synthetics
they had Springs
styrofoam and all of these things
together had to be Blended and so we
just went in and we restructured the way
the company who did the manufacturing
and it turned out to be a fun process
but the you know the fashion industry is
is it's tough but
I I just I don't follow any other rules
and the ones I've worked on for 35 years
it's
as you go in and it's the philosophy of
cooperative
uh
change design thinking in a group
transformation with a group
and when you present the idea you
present it to the
owner is a change team rather than as an
individual if one guy is it's all his
idea on the team and then the other guys
aren't going to necessarily support him
but if it's a team effort to make the
presentation then it works
I'd like to also offer another example
from The Real World in the fashion
industry of how
the notion of design of
visual design and that type of thing one
way of
interpret side to design thinking which
is looking at organizational change
made a huge difference and that's the
Spanish fashion company Zara
Zara makes what invented the the
segment called Fast fashion and what
that means is they can take a design
that they've seen from another
manufacturer and adapt it and produce
clothes and get them into the stores
within a matter of a week or two
and this is something that's entirely
new or was entirely new at the time in
the fashion industry what they were able
to the reason they were able to do this
is because of digital transformation and
so it wasn't a matter of design thinking
in terms of
what are the colors shapes Fabrics that
we're going to be using it was more in
the for them it was how do we get
information from our stores about what
is selling
um
how do we then transmit that to our
manufacturing facilities to produce more
of that and get those things
skip to our stores quickly and how do we
keep updating that and looking for new
trends so that we're constantly turning
over
the products in our Stores
um to match what the demand is from
customers and it's a phenomenal system
but it's based on the notion of the
digital technology to collect the data
to interpret the data and then to
transmit it out for actionable
subscriptions to manufacturing and
shipping and Merchandising and that's a
good example that's a real good example
because that
anytime you're working an industry and
you can create
uh
call it a homogeneous uh production and
distribution system
under your single control
that that's going to give you the the
best results and digital transformation
is the vehicle that this is happening
more and more I mean you know 25 years
ago I had a client that was whining to
me that he was getting ripped off by the
Chinese who would steal his designs
before he could get him to the market
and they would have a competitive
product before he could he could get the
market present with his product and you
know they were just using early versions
of that
mm-hmm
leads to a question from olomi who asks
what's the first thing to consider if
you're implementing a digital
transformation in an organization
let's see the first thing
well it starts at the Top If you cannot
progress through a digital
transformation unless the CEO buys into
it step one
and
I've had number of people come to me and
say I'd like to come in and have you do
my do your problem solving change and
I'm in It's let's say through a CFO or a
CE
c-o-o or someone other than the CEO
and the reason that you have to start at
the CEO is that the CEO is in charge of
strategy
and that that no one else in the company
is in charge of
and so when you want to make change in
an organization it has to start with a
CEO
because all of that all of the strategy
is radically affected by any kinds of
programs that you implement because for
instance if if you can get a product to
Market quicker you can start
implementing way back when just in time
production techniques
but again if you do that it changes your
delivery relationship with suppliers
that all the way through the system so
you have to have
that CEO involved from the very
beginning so I would I would say if you
don't have the CEO involved it's pretty
hard to work from the bottom up
to the CEO and then get them convinced
and then work back down
but boy it's painful yeah
sheetal asked uh
she's always been a business consultant
for eight years and he's curious to know
what is the best way to make top
management understand the importance of
change and of allowing feedback
and adopting that no blame strategy
how do you get old dogs to learn new
drugs say do you have a two by four
handy uh it it's the old joke about how
do you get the attention of the jackass
is that the guy out the farmer goes out
and takes a two by four and hits him
over the head but that's sort of like
what you have to do because a lot of
times CEOs think they're the smartest
guy on the street and they're not
there they have to understand that there
is a tremendous amount of Genius
um within their organization that they
need to tap into and I I don't quite
frankly I don't know how you
as a consultant
cause a CEO to change other than the way
I did it was
I convinced one CEO
and then let him sell someone else and
so literally over the years I I haven't
really had to do much selling it's all
been referral
you know why don't you talk to Lynn and
then if the CEO wants to talk to Lynn
and I talk to him and then convince him
that I have a good idea
and then you can work down from there
but boy any other way and I I think it's
very you can do it
you could provide Educational Tools and
you know I've done seminars for CEOs
I put together a thing I called short
attention span theater for CEOs it was
an hour with a whole bunch of 15-minute
talks that the CEO could come in listen
to them and then get out
CEOs think their time is so valuable
they can't spend any more an hour hour
and a half
and but they would do that and I could
get some CEOs doing that but I
yeah just that was that was too much
work you had to find a list of some sort
that you could go send to emails to CEOs
and then
get them to come you know come out of
their office to go to this presentation
now you can use the webinar like we're
doing here to get them
um
somewhere but for the most part
um referral is is what I would do I
would work like heck to get one
convinced and then use him to leverage
everyone else
another aspect that the two by four that
you mentioned one of the one of the
things that acts like a 2x4 to a CEO's
head is
when their competition introduces a
product that completely outclasses what
they have or when they start seeing
uh
bad returns or bad performance in their
company so that kind of fear starts to
open up people's minds to
the notion of doing things differently
if they're smart if they're not smart
they just try to do more of what they
've always been doing and watch it
spiral in but
um
you know the question and answer how do
you get to the CEO to talk well you can
go to Executive business groups like YPO
and uh
um
there are a number of them out there
that
the Executive Club I can't remember all
of them but that you can go to those
Club groups and make presentations and
then you you can make your pitch as to
why they should think about adopting
your thinking to make change in the
company
and
uh that that turned out to be okay I
made a number of
successful uh engagements doing that
we have a couple more questions if you
have time
um Ramesh asked a related question how
do you deal with business people who
believe in decision making decisions
with their gut
um how do you how do you get them to
look beyond that and start considering
scientific thinking and data-driven
methods
well there are two two parts of that one
whether your gut
is a bad source of decision making
and
how do you do make decision making with
the data that you get from
digital
uh information
and there's nothing wrong with making a
decision by you know I have experience
and
we've always done it this way
and
this is the way we're going to do it and
when somebody is in that position
there's really almost nothing you can do
as a as an employee if someone is using
our gut
but two
to get somebody to start using uh
analytical tools to make decisions
you just have to give them enough
information
that allows them to see
the uh effective use of that material
give them an Insight that they couldn't
get on their own
and uh
literally I think if I went into a
hundred of the clients that I've done in
the past that every single one of them
would have learned a lot from having uh
listened to the presentations by their
employees because there there's always
one
uh idea that they get from that
that they would have never thought of
before
because they can't make a present in the
process I have is they cannot make a
presentation unless they have the data
to back it up
and I'll give you a good example is that
one of my clients was a manufacturer DNA
materials
you know the little segments of DNA
they're called oligos
and
the
the group was trying to figure it was
trying to convince the CEO
that his gut was wrong this is as you
were been talking I this one idea came
up and and
that his gut was wrong and so they
needed to get some data
so one of the roles we all know in
business is the 80 20 rule 80 percent of
the benefit comes from 20 percent of the
either
uh
uh products that you sell or eighty
percent of your problems come from 20 of
your customers and on and on and on
but I'd identified a corollary to that
years ago and it's called the 567 5 of
your problems come for
67 of your problems come from five
percent of your customers or in this
particular case
67 percent of the shipment problems came
from five percent of the products
and so the what that did that meant that
you take a team of five people they're
shipping let's say 400 invoices a month
and they could easily grab five percent
of that
or 20 of them
and
do an analysis of those so they did that
and when they laid the data on the CEO
it just blew him away so that you you
use the scientific techniques
in the I think one 567 is one of my the
I think my most powerful tool because
people you know are trying to make a
case to a CEO or some executive
and they figure they don't have the time
well just take five percent and see what
happens
it's it's amazing because there if you
look at the graph and I wrote a book on
567 thinking
and
it allows you to do that kind of thing
is that you you parcel the problem down
into something that's very manageable
and you do you work on that then sell
that up the Stream
and that takes the gut out of the issue
so uh you know when somebody has a gut
and you can't counter it
he's going to go with his gut but if you
can give him some data that says we need
to do this because of this and he said
you know like if you if you inspect it
did a hundred of items instead of you
did 400 invoices instead of 20. would
your result have been any different
probably not so that's the Assumption
they're going on
um so we're running out of time but I do
want to ask the one last question
because Sandra asks have you written
books and what are the names of those
books so uh
if you'd let me know what which titles
of those books are
I'll include links to the Amazon it's
easy Stuart you go to my website
www.copsolversc-o-p-s-o-l-v-e-r-s.com
and I have my library in there
perfect
and then I'll include that in fact I can
put that into the chat right now
you said it is
by the way
books I would read read the one first
it's called the war on waste paradox
and that's a story about a worker who
goes through my
uh
what I call the war on waste it was at
the at the time I wrote that it was the
war and waste today it's
it sounds High Roi problem solving
very good because that relates to a
question somebody asked about uh
helping to reduce waste uh in their home
country so that would be a great place
for them to start and so with that I'm
going to apologize for not getting to
everyone else's questions
and we'll move on to the final part of
our
presentation here
um
so uh
people asked about how you find out
about design thinking and
uh simply learn portions in the business
of uh
professional technical education we have
a program with Purdue University it's a
professional certificate program in
digital transformation uh a six-month
online program
um we designed in collaboration with
Purdue University which is one of
the world's leading universities
um comprehensive curriculum it has
integrated case studies and projects
with online virtual classroom
instructions so it's not just watching
videos
um and it is flexible so that you can
schedule most of the work around your
work or life schedule it builds up or
digital transformation skills step by
step
students
you learn digital disruption and
strategies for digital transformation
you learn design thinking
um then you move on to Agile business
transformation and digital marketing and
marketing strategies in the digital
ecosystem
and on to digital leadership and finally
a Capstone project where you integrate
all of these skills into
um one final business model for a new
digital business of your own design
along the way you can take electives
master classes from Purdue and KPMG
Personnel you can take
AWS technical Essentials to learn about
the cloud
a big data in Hadoop learn about the
internet of things and artificial
intelligence all the electives of course
are included in the cost uh at your
discretion
and you end up with certificates both
from Purdue and KPMG
um along with the experience that you
can point to in the case studies in the
Capstone project
and so that
is one of the options we have for
learning about digital transformation
and design thinking so I just want to
ask a quick question based on that
thumbnail description
um how many folks in the audience are
interested in learning more about the
program
and um what time frame are you
interested in learning
so we're going to let this whole
question run for about 20 seconds
and again we haven't shared with you all
of the information but while we're
running the poll I will
put into the chat
a link
the two resources one is the program
home page on our website and the other
is an email address which allows you to
talk to one of our learning consultants
and ask questions about that so
in the chat got that email and that web
link
here's the answer to the poll
again
um
80 or more uh
mayor are interested or may be
interested in uh this program so please
do check the program page at the link I
just shared and please do email us ask
us at simplylearn.net and ask a learning
consultant for more information
um with that I'm going to thank Len for
being here and you have uh on his on the
screen here you see lambertane is how
you find him on LinkedIn
and I've shared with you the email
address cop solvers
.com which is a website for the
Consortium of problem solvers
so then thank you so much for being here
you're welcome very much and I hope by
transferred some information to the
people they could use
great and
just want to invite everyone to keep in
touch with simply learn at our social
media channels at simply learn at
Facebook Twitter simply learn on
LinkedIn we have these types of webinars
regularly and we're backed on a frequent
schedule so please do check our website
or check your email and we'll include a
link to the next one in our follow-up
email to you which will include links to
this program recording and the PDF of
today's slide so that you can review
those and
thank you all for being here very very
much we hope to see you at future
webinars we hope that we can welcome you
into the simply learned learning
community
that ends our presentation thanks